- [Mark Laita] All right. Rose
- Okay.
- [Mark Laita] Rose where did you grow up?
Where are you from originally
- [Rose] I'm born and raised
right here, Downtown LA.
- [Mark Laita] On Skid Row?
- [Rose] On Skid Row.
- [Mark Laita] Wow. And tell
me about your family then.
Is it an interesting story?
- My mom is from Cuba,
My dad is from Belize
but we was born and raised down here.
I have six siblings, brothers and sisters.
My mom had four girls and two boys.
My mom died when I was 16 years old.
My dad OD'd in front of me when I was 8.
And I've never been
outside of Downtown LA.
I've always been here
because this is the
only place that I know.
I started using drugs
when I was 8 years old.
And I'm 42 years old now.
So I've been on it for 40,
almost 40 something years.
And I just decided to get
clean like about two months ago
because I feel like that's
not the life for me.
And I have nine kids.
I have five girls and four boys,
and I gave custody up to my kids dad
because I didn't want to put them
through what I went through out here.
I know what this life is like.
I thank God that I've
never been raped or beaten
but it's because I've been homeless,
I hear all the time.
I live in a tent on the
next street, on Allica,
and I've been homeless for 42 years.
I've been taking care of my own self.
At the age of 10 years old
I had my own apartment by selling dope.
That's all I really know
how to do is cook dope.
I became the best cooker in Downtown LA.
So quite naturally, everybody wanted me
because a lot of people just
don't know how to make dope.
But now since Google's
showing you how to do it.
But I just feel like it's
something that keeps me down here.
I think that it's because I
lost my mom and dad down here
and when I go anywhere else,
I don't feel them around me.
- [Mark Laita] It feels like home?
- Yeah. I feel like this is home.
If I leave anywhere and I don't
see the downtown buildings,
I get paranoid and anybody does it.
You know, I'm in the car,
we'd have to bring me back because
these are the only streets
that my mom and dad walked
when I was a little girl
and this is the only place I know.
All my brothers and sisters moved.
Like, all my sisters live in Bakersfield.
My brothers live in Inglewood,
but I choose to stay Downtown LA
and I don't know why.
- [Mark Laita] How about you and school?
- I made it to the ninth grade.
I was a freshman.
I had a learning disability,
like, I don't read and spell good,
but I'm learning.
And I just remain teachable.
I know every day is a
learning experience for me.
And one thing I appreciate
about my mom and dad is
they taught me how to take care of myself
at such a young age.
Due to the fact that all they done.
My dad was a loan shark.
My mom, all they did is do drugs.
So we had to learn to
take care of ourselves.
We had to learn to cook for ourselves,
we had to learn to take
a shower for ourselves
because they was on drugs
and she didn't have time to do that.
And that's why I choose to give my kids up
because I want a better life for them.
I don't want them to have to go through
what I've been through.
- [Mark Laita] What was your
favorite memory as a kid?
- My memory as a kid is my mom and dad
walking us around these streets,
going up and down these streets,
and that I take the same route
as when I was a little girl.
And what's a coincidence,
I think it's a blessing,
is my dad died in the Alexandria hotel,
which is one of the most
famous hotels down here,
and now that's where my mail goes.
I've been back since the
age of 8 years old to now,
42 years later, I'm
back in the same hotel.
I'm right down the hall
from where we lived when I was a kid.
- [Mark Laita] So you're in
a hotel or you're in a tent?
- I'm out here but my friend and I
take our showers and all
my mail go over there.
So I go over there.
I'm able to go in and take a shower,
warm up and come back out.
- [Mark Laita] But you've
been living in a tent
for how long?
- I've been living in my tent for now,
almost 25 years.
- [Mark Laita] Can you live in a-
- Yeah, I live in a tent-
- [Mark Laita] No, can you live in a house
or an apartment?
- Yeah, if I had the-
I don't receive no GR no nothing because-
- [Mark Laita] So how do
you support yourself now?
- Right now I just got a job
working at the medical
center across the street.
And that's how I've
been supporting myself.
Doing that and selling drugs.
- [Mark Laita] You were
selling drugs up until when,
just recently?
- Just recently. I just
stopped two months ago
when I got my job right
here across the street.
- [Mark Laita] What motivated you
to change your life around?
- Tired of going to jail.
I'm tired of going to jail.
People say they got your
back, but they don't.
And I realized that I was a fool
because I'm out here selling
drugs for other people
and when I go to jail, nobody
puts money on my books.
- [Mark Laita] But there's
probably something deeper
than tired of going to jail
that's behind that.
- Well you gotta be sick and
tired of being sick and tired.
I know where it takes me.
And I know this life.
And I know that if I don't stop,
you see there's only two things,
jails, institution or death.
And I don't want either one of those.
I want to be something in this life.
I want my kids to have
something in his life.
I don't want them to have
their mom die as a junkie
like my mom did.
- [Mark Laita] Who introduced
you to drugs at 8 years old?
- All the people that I
was around, my mom and dad.
I picked it up from my mom.
I used to watch how they do it.
And one day she put it down
and she went to the store.
And when she came back, I picked it up.
- [Mark Laita] That was crack?
- Crack cocaine.
That was back in the 80s
when it was real crack.
Now I don't know what it is,
but that's what made me
motivate me to change my life.
Because I want something better.
I always like to work and have a job
because I always like to have my own.
I don't like to get something
or to borrow something.
I ask people for something
and then they throw it up to your face.
So I believe the best
way is to be independent
and learn from my mistakes.
I live and I learn.
That's why I like Little Wayne's song.
He say he a rookie and a vet
but he still remain teachable.
- [Mark Laita] Well, so what
do you think the difference is
between you and everyone
else here on Skid Row,
who just seems content
to stay here forever?
- My thing, I think the difference is,
is everybody have choices
and it's up to us
what we make and what we want.
I believe that they struggling
the fence right now.
They battling with good and evil.
And the devil is powerful,
like Jesus is powerful,
but only if we let them win.
And if you want to do better,
you're going to do better.
I think what keeps them down here
is that they lose their
morals and their values.
They forget the way their
parents raised them.
They lose all home bases.
And when they come out here
they get adapted to the new
rules, the street rules,
which is the wrong rules,
'cause the streets don't love nobody.
- [Mark Laita] Yeah, but the street life
seems to be very addictive
for a lot of people.
- It's very addictive because of the drugs
and the weak souls that's out here.
Because it's very powerful,
but we all have a choice too.
What we want to make with our lives.
Sometimes you got to go.
Some people gotta hit rock bottom.
And some people just know
when it's time to let it go.
And me, I want to live.
And to live down here, I
have to be clean and sober.
If not, I'm going to be walking around
like these crazy women.
Bare feeted, with no clothes on
running up and down the
street, talking to myself.
And I always pray to God
that I never be like that.
And I thank God that I haven't yet.
- [Mark Laita] What's
been your lowest point?
- Me choosing this life, the
Skid Row life over my kids.
That's my lowest.
I was willing to give my kids up
so that I can be out here on drugs.
That's the lowest.
- [Mark Laita] What do you think
most people that don't do drugs
don't understand about addiction?
- It is where it could
take you and the things-
- [Mark Laita] But it's
not a conscious choice
these people make.
- No, it's something that's happened.
It's like having a
gorilla on your shoulder
and you're fighting him
but he's holding on.
That's what it's like.
It's hard.
- [Mark Laita] Do you have friends.
- No.
- [Mark Laita] Have you ever had friends?
- I don't believe in friends.
Friends is backstabbers.
The only friends is my family.
That's the only friends I need.
And my kids.
- [Mark Laita] You ever been in love?
- In love? Yeah.
I was with my kids dad for 28 years.
9 kids by the same man.
And I went to prison for selling drugs.
When I got out, he cheated on me.
And that's why I been out here ever since.
I just choose to do my own thing.
But I choose not to let
nobody get close to me.
'Cause the flesh was made for sins
and I have trust issues
because I give people
the benefit of the doubt.
And just what I think they're gonna to do
is what they try to do.
But I already be prepared for it.
So I believe if you stay ready,
you don't have to get ready.
- [Mark Laita] What's
the most important lesson
you've learned in all your years out here?
- [Rose] How to not do nothing to others
that I don't want done to me.
Treat people the way I want to be treated.
It's like the concept, empathy.
The ability to imagine how others feel.
And in order to progress
your empathetic skills,
you must ask yourself,
"How would you feel under
the same circumstances?"
That's what I think.
- [Mark Laita] So with
all your time down here
living on the streets,
what qualities do you
think you've developed
that most people don't have.
The street life is very different.
- [Rose] How to love myself.
That I can't love others,
unless I love myself
because I can tell everybody
I love you, but do I love me?
If I don't love me?
How can I love someone else.
And how to be loyal.
Because I don't do nothing
to them, but they do to me.
And they have done a lot of things to me,
and what I do, I pray for them.
And I asked God to help
them and to forgive them
because they know not what they do.
- [Mark Laita] What has
helped you gain the ability
to love yourself
- To me is being able to accept my world.
Being able to realize
that I'm my worst enemy.
That no one could do nothing to me,
unless I allow them to.
To be able to wake up and make a choice.
Am I just gonna sit on
the ground and be a bum
or am I gonna go out and look for a job?
Am I just going to sit here
and get drunk and get high
and say, poor me, poor me
or am I going to do
something about my life
to make it better?
That's what I believe it is.
- [Mark Laita] Can you imagine
what your life would have been like
if you had two parents that raised you
and stuck together and didn't-
- Yeah, I probably wouldn't
have never did drugs.
Well, I really don't regret it
because I learned from all of it.
The only thing I just miss my mom and dad
but I know they my guardian angels
and they with me
and that they would want
to see me doing better
than what I've been doing.
- [Rose] And so that's my goal.
Is to do better for
myself and for my kids.
- [Mark Laita] All right Rose.
Thank you so much for sharing your story.
- Thank you so much.
- [Mark Laita] I wish
you the best of luck.
Thank you. God bless you.
- [Rose] So what do you think?
- [Mark Laita] Finally a positive story.
- [Rose] I know you got it.
- [Mark Laita] I got so many dark ones.